[Musique]
la famille beaulieu accueille un nouveau
membre zoé acheté chez un éleveur
après deux jours fruit devient très
malade
monsieur beaulieu demande à l'éleveur de
l'examiner mais il refuse la famille n'a
d'autre choix que d'en mais la chienne
chez le vétérinaire qui diagnostiquent
une gastrite zoé est hospitalisé
quelques jours elle retrouve la santé
mais monsieur beaulieu lui demande de
mourir en voyant la facture jouer et
elle garantit depuis 2015 le québec
reconnaît que les animaux ne sont pas
dédiés ce sont des êtres doués de
sensibilité mais ils sont considérés
quand même comme des biens en ce qui
concerne la garantie
zoé avait un vice caché et elle est
couverte par la garantie légale
monsieur bré but est donc en droit de
réclamer les frais de vétérinaire à son
élevage
le fin mot de l'histoire rien ne peut
garantir l'amour de jouer mais il y a
une garantie sur son état de santé